zendaya reveals her 21st birthday plans
and the future of her hit Disney show
I'm growing up and there's a lot of
other things I want to do in my career
hey friends this is the daily Deni and
I'm telling you right now we have a
jam-packed show for you today starting
with my girls and daya the 20 year old
was shining shimmering splendid last
night in this sparkling Iveta pants ooh
a varieties young Hollywood party our
girl is having a major year with
spider-man homecoming and her upcoming
film the greatest showman with Hugh
Jackman that's why I had to find out
from G herself with the future holds for
her Disney Channel show you know
obviously you do say big things right
now a lot of fans are know this is the
last piece of Casey undercover things
[Music]
just because you know thank you I'm
growing up and there's a lot of other
things I want to do in my career and you
know it I'm kind of Casey is you know
she's going up she's coming a woman and
there's been a lot of talk this season
about like her going to college and her
you know moving on and moving in
different directions in her life so I
think though you're moving on and moving
in different directions
there you have it folks and Zendaya's
co-star Veronica dune told me she agrees
they've had a great run and everybody's
going up in fact India herself is about
to hit a milestone birthday here's how
she plans to celebrate you know you're
not going to be a youngin for too long
you're about to turn 21 how do you plan
to celebrate doing nothing I know you
focus on being really heard but I'm not
really my house probably well my family
yeah keep it low-key with the fam why
not right wish I could say the same
about my 21st I love that girl you know
she also talked to me about those pesky
Tom Holland dating rumors that's up now
on et online.com but from a rumor
romance to a storied romance I'm talking
about Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay whose
quest for love ended with a proposal
from Brian not Peter many fans were up
in arms about the final pic joining us
now in defense of Brian
Lauren Zima you guys I have just come in
from New York where I interviewed Rachel
and Brian I did
not even doing makeup I was on two red
eyes just to speak to the best ribs but
you do speak to The Bachelor and Brian I
know a lot of people were skeptical
about him have you talked to them tell
me what's your take are they the real
deal here's the thing they seem super in
love and super happy during her
interview they would not stop holding
hands it's very different from like the
Nick vile Vanessa situation after their
show ended which one's tense your reach
membrane seems super happy and I know
everybody loves Peter but guys it's okay
we can just let Peter be the patch learn
I was going to say Eddie what are the
prospects because I know we were team
Peter were the prospects of him becoming
the next factor so I actually I gotta
get myself credit for this when I went
on Rachel's group date in Hilton Head
months ago I asked Peter about that and
even then he did not roll the
possibility out even when he was kind of
dating Rachel and now he's giving up
more interviews about it to talk to GMA
he said you know it's not a no for me
sometimes usually means it's a yes I'm
tuning in if he's it
I'm tuning in for sure that stories up
on et Online Laurie don't get some rest
girl I gotta go get some rest and dream
about Peter I mean while Aaron Carter is
feeling the support since coming out as
bisexual but the 29 year old claims his
ex girlfriend Madison Parker did not
have the same reaction Erin and Madison
called it quits
over the weekend around the same time he
opened up about his sexuality during a
phone interview with the Bert show on
Wednesday Erin shared how that
conversation between his ex Clint I had
discussed it with my ex-girlfriend and
they really understand it she didn't
want you know now that he so we left it
all kind of visual and you know parted
ways and seems to be honest like I'm
alone right now and I would like to have
a relationship sorry a little Carrie I
just went to a briefing
Erin also said whether I should be with
a woman or a man is my decision no one
else's and I say amen to that
all right Erin of course is starting a
new chapter in his life we got to talk
about an early chapter and Han Solo
story for that more rocket welcome back
resident movie expert ash crossing I was
20 minutes late today because I was
stuck in my card reading this article
it's so enthralling so enthralling
Donald Glover is what we're talking
about he plays Lando in the untitled Han
Solo movie he Grace's beautiful face on
the cover of a
Hollywood Reporter but he has something
to say about the director shake-up
absolutely so we kind of in stand down
played a little bit maybe there was a
drama and he kind of tried to downplay
it but he was quite candid and what
articles saying that you know it was
kind of a changing of the guard and then
you have a new boss and he's like do
they like me
do they not mi mi their first choice I
don't think so and you like you've
really got that perspective of him of
being on set doing these takes maybe not
feeling comfortable with Ron Howard
saying does he like me or not like the
Empire there right Rand right the doubt
starts to sink in who would be better
than him it'll be ugly and you know he
did get the blessing of Billy Dee
Williams who played Lando I think they
met three months right after he got cast
yeah we saw them in I think January with
that picture together in disguise kind
of having a dinner but it's kind of
funny because when you read this you see
that Donald Glover's mind goes out
million miles a minute he has all these
ideas for Lando and Billy's like I don't
know about that but you got a well does
so like the torch has been officially
passed and we shall hold out hope for
the Han Solo movie I know you're sure
I'm sure
all right Thank You Ashley to you you
guys be sure to subscribe to ETS youtube
channel so you don't miss daily denny
and also ashley show behind the screen
as always head over to ET online.com for
all these stories and a whole lot more
told you it was jam-packed alright I'll
see ya